any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic michael
knowles
author of many books many wonderful
books now
some with words some without if you put
together
his previous book which i have here
reasons to vote for democrats
if you put it next to and combine it
with speechless you get
a pretty good book you get kind of the
the some total of a career brian i i
fear
that you know i've spent about a year
writing this book i think it's making
points
that have not really been made in the
conservative space i think it's making
very important points
about political correctness about
language about censorship and the simple
fact is
it will never live up to my first book
it was my my first blank book was the
magnum opus
this i hope is is my modest sequel
well indeed it is and if nothing else
just the footnotes
and the citations at the very end are
the length of
of a normal best-selling page-turning
book and this is
i got it two days ago from uh one of
your assistants there
uh i want to thank you for that but
unfortunately it's so large
that you know i i haven't gotten past
the equations in chapter four yet so i'm
working through those equations
i salute you for all of einstein's
general relativistic field equations
we'll get to all that at the end
why am i having michael knowles on the
into the impossible podcast the top 10
science podcast on itunes and other
places
well he is a scientist he is a knowledge
maven
he has deconstructed and reconstructed
our popular culture and he and i have
been together we've talked about galileo
and his contributions to
not only to science but to writing as
well and you can look for an episode
i'll put a link to our
our book club episode that we did
together and he's also uh uh he's been
on the
guest on the podcast before but uh today
it's to celebrate the release
of his new book which came out today uh
it's called speechless and so michael i
love to play a game
uh which is called uh which is called
you know
cover judging you know judging a book by
its cover so i want to ask you
uh this is kind of obvious how you got
up with this cover how did you come up
with the cover
and the title of speechless so the title
of speechless was a little bit of a nod
to my first work
uh which had no words this has many
words and it's speechless
but i uh the full title is controlling
words and controlling minds
and the cover you know is the guy with
the with the
gag on his mouth now the reason for this
is i know that there's been a lot of
right wing talk about how we're being
silenced by the left
and we support free speech and they're
censoring us and
unfortunately i think that so much of
that talk about wokeness and political
correctness
and cancel culture has been shallow
i think that in many ways the victim
narrative that the right has
has portrayed that we are the stalwart
defenders of absolute total free speech
and the leftists they're the
authoritarian censors
i i think look it maybe that may be true
right now
but that doesn't really get to the whole
picture okay the fact is
that in the 1950s you could be canceled
for being a communist
and it wasn't the left canceling you it
was conservatives canceling you
for being a communist then the fact is
today you can be canceled for being an
anti-communist and that's a problem too
but really what we're describing here
is not just the purely negative terrible
thing that happens now
of how people control words to control
minds but how
really whoever is controlling the words
is controlling the minds the words
that we use the the pronouns and
the verbs and the nouns and the
adjectives and all the other words
do shape the way that we view the world
and there
are going to be limits to what we can
say language itself
imposes limits if if we call for
instance
uh bruce jenner caitlyn jenner now as
she
then we are not calling him a he if
caitlyn jenner really is a she
then that says something about reality
that says something about the limits of
what we are
permitted to perceive in the society and
the the right used to understand this
the wright used to understand that there
are
limits to speech and to society and that
there are just
standards i guess is what you'd call it
and
the left i think successfully engaged in
a campaign
to destroy those standards from 1920 to
say 1960 1970
when it really broke into the main that
was called political correctness
and they've now convinced the right that
we should abandon standards
entirely so you'll notice the more and
more we fight back about against
political correctness over the last 30
40 years
the more ground we have lost both the
people who give in to the left's new
standards obviously they've
caused us to lose ground but even the
people who say you know i'm a free
speech absolutist
i think they've caused us to lose ground
too i think this is a trap laid by pc
and i think either way those traditional
standards are abandoned
and the left because nature abhors a
vacuum has filled
that that vacuum with their own radical
standard that's totally redefined
society so i knew you would uh bring in
some physics there you're dropping some
aristotle on us
already with nature aboard a vacuum you
know most of what aristotle said about
physics turns out to be absolutely wrong
that there were
only four elements earth air wind and
fire that heavy things fall faster than
lighter things
all things that he could have observed
with his eyes as galileo would later do
as you and i discussed as we talked
about the parapathetics
but on contradistinction to his laws on
physics his thoughts on politics are run
through speechless and you really
trace that through line and make it very
bright i want to ask
what is the legacy of aristotle and how
do you reconcile this guy
who got so much wrong about observable
things and yet was so right about things
that are purely
hypothetical or intellectual like
political animus
uh the political animal that he
described mankind as
yes aristotle for a guy who you know
obviously he got some things wrong about
the natural world there's no con
no no debating that though i think we
should give him a little bit of a break
he lived a very long time ago did not
have access
to quite the same technology that we do
and i think it's worth pointing out
actually getting back to our discussion
of galileo some months ago galileo got a
lot of things wrong about the natural
world yeah actually the
the central uh aspect i suppose of his
famous
discourses he he gets wrong the the way
that the tides were
you know he gets a lot of things right
but he gets that wrong too so yes
aristotle
gets some things wrong and he did get
right by the way as you and i discussed
you know the very very important
uh to both of us uh the notion that
whales are mammals
uh aristotle was the first to point that
out so mazel tov to go to
arizona but yeah go on so how did this
notion what is a political animal
are you a political animal are we all
political animals talk about that we are
not
not just us total political junkies who
follow all the websites
but all of us are political animals when
aristotle says
that man is the political animal he he
means that
the defining feature of man is that we
are sociable
we form society we are not contrary to
the modern i think
ultra super duper libertarian or liberal
idea we're not just free-floating atoms
we're actually
always in the state of nature or
otherwise we're always together
we're always forming societies the word
political refers to the paulus right the
greek city-state
and aristotle says the thing that makes
us political is our speech
animals grunt and occasionally our
politicians seem to grunt as well but
you like to hope at their higher end
that they're engaging in speech which
refers to objective reality
and the way that we use speech
especially in a self-governing republic
such as ours
is we use it to persuade one another we
use it to have debate we use it to try
to make sense of the world
and how we're all going to get along
together in accordance with one another
and in accordance with society so when
you control the language
as the left has done not just through
the government
but through our educational institutions
through hollywood through the mass media
through big technology which will
outright censor people now for saying
perfectly
ordinary and accurate things when you
control the speech in a society
you're not just controlling one little
aspect you know the first amendment is
not just one little amendment in the
whole
in the whole body politic you really
controlling the whole thing this is why
when google or facebook or twitter these
these handful of oligarchs in silicon
valley hipster rasputin out there mr
jack dorsey
when they control speech they're really
controlling our whole
politics and so it is not just a side
issue or an aspect of the culture war
really when we're talking about
political correctness we're talking
about the whole damn thing
and what do you say to those critics who
say uh and these are just some people
i've had on my show
uh dave rubin a man by the name of ben
shapiro
uh i've heard of those michael shermer
um
james lindsay who i know heather
mcdonald who i know
i haven't had candace owens on i don't
know if i will i don't know how much uh
how much thermodynamic energy i can
handle uh
uh senator force of nature there she is
yeah senator ted cruz who you share the
verdict podcast with
shout out to that and ann coulter i
haven't heard her i'm not sure i will
but anyway all these incomia
appear in and on your book michael i
have to give you a tip as someone who's
written a book that had words in it
before
you got to leave some room for people to
buy the book you know if you
sent them all the book now they're not
going to buy it but anyway um so
how can you you know this this uh
supposedly victim potentially victim of
cancellation how can you decry this when
all these people these ladies and
gentlemen
have written books about the evil you
know suppression of speech
and ideas coming from the left how can
you say that with all these books and
that's just a handful of the ones i've
mentioned that have been on my show
there are lots of very prominent people
who have endorsed speechless and i'm
very appreciative to them
lots of political people from different
whole different parts of the right
you've got people like adrian vermeuel
who is a harvard law professor very he's
a catholic integralist
you've got ben shapiro he's certainly
not a catholic integral lest he is
probably more on the libertarian side of
the conservative movement
senator cruz and coulter all sorts of
people yes
i am not saying that i
am being censored i'm not saying that
i've been canceled
there have been high profile attempts to
cancel me on occasion
and i'm pleased to to say that i've
survived those attempts even from
powerful institutions
uh i i'm reminded of winston churchill's
phrase
when he was describing i think he was in
cuba at the time someone shot at him and
he survived and he said i it was the
first time i ever had the
the joy of being shot at to no effect
that's right it's a very nice thing but
i'm i'm not saying that i'm i'm being
censored right now i'm saying something
a little more dire
we are all being rendered speechless i
don't it doesn't matter how many people
download my podcast big tech tries to
censor my podcast on occasion but
sometimes they let them through
sometimes
amazon uh throws up some obstacles to
listing this book
sometimes they let it through that
that's not the the issue
the issue is the way in which the left
has broadly
uh reshaped what is inbounds and what is
out of bounds in society
truly today if you go onto the internet
and you say
that a transgender person you know a man
who identifies as a woman
if you refer to that specific man as a
man you call him he
or you call him by his proper name
instead of whatever new name he's
adopted
you very likely will be taken off of
the internet not 100 guaranteed the
rules are opaque
but it's it's possible and probable
actually that you will
i i give these speaking events at
colleges around the country
and some of them i think are
controversial and some of them really
are not controversial
and the only one where i was physically
attacked was at the event that should
have been the least controversial of all
where i said
this very topic men are not women
if you come out and you say on the
internet that there were
any questions about the 2020 election
any hint of impropriety or fraud if you
point out
the plain fact that the pennsylvania
election officials
violated the state constitution and the
way they conducted that election
you are liable to be taken off of the
internet now for some people
we have a big enough audience we have a
big enough platform
that big tech is going to think twice
about taking us off or they'll do it in
a very clever way
for a lot of people who have who don't
have a large platform their accounts
will just be deleted
they will just be shut up and it's uh
arbitrary in many ways because there
aren't fixed rules there are
double standards and triple and
quadruple standards
but really what we're talking about here
is the exercise of power
uh one of the observers of political
correctness in its early days pointed
out
that political corrupt i think was
angelo codevilla pointed out that
political correctness
is less about the rules themselves the
rules are always changing the terms are
always changing
it's much more about the imposition who
can force you to say and think what they
want you to
so yes i hope and i i expect that my
book will be allowed to stay on big tech
platforms at least for now
have a nice big podcast and reach a lot
of people but what are the bounds
of discourse now the the traditional i
don't even mean traditional
over the last 15 20 years the
conservative response to this
to the left imposing newer and more
restrictive rules
around our speech has been to say hey
we've got to get rid of all the rules
entirely you should be able to
say whatever you want and do they really
mean this do they really mean that you
should be able to walk up to the water
cooler
john from accounting walks up to the
water cooler in his office he's got a
swastika armband and he starts yelling
zig hyle in the workplace
he should really be allowed to do i
don't think so i don't think it would be
cancel culture
if he is fired conservatives once
understood this
william f buckley jr used almost the
same example he said
academic freedom as we understand it
today is really just a hoax no one
believes
no one believes that yale university's
sociology department should hire a
neo-nazi
to teach about the superiority of the
aryan no one thinks
they would do that nor should they of
course there are going to be
limits and standards the question is
what are those standards and i think
will conservatives
have the philosophical sophistication
and more importantly the courage
to actually assert them i once heard you
know that
hopefully donald trump lives a long life
i hope he has a nice time
but someday death comes for us all when
he dies
one hopes that he donates his body to
science and his spine to the
conservative movement because
the the i think so much of the reason
we've lost
our our speech is because
we are unwilling to to exercise the the
virtue of courage
and one of the messages that comes
through in the book is that you know
uh as i often say i think most debate
is pointless i don't know a single
person who's gone into a debate
you know thank you so much ida bay wells
or you know whatever uh
her name hannah um uh nicole
nicole hannah jones uh uh pulitzer prize
winner
you know oh thank you you changed my
mind you know thank you i can't imagine
you and ben shapiro you know really
coming to agreement on it
so what is the purpose of debate and
putting it out there and uh through line
in the book
as i take it is that uh you know it's
almost depressing if one is a
conservative
that you know the attempts to to date
have been one of
compassionate conservatism of george
bush and and it's always the guy who is
in office you know two offices ago that
gets all the credit and he hugs
you know the current president or you
know and then he gets cancelled last and
it's kind of that churchill quip that
you know
giving in to the mob is like feeding an
alligator hoping you get eaten last
but i wonder you kind of come off a
little bit depressive in or it's
depressing if one is a conservative
to think that the more you fight the
worse it gets for say your side and the
um
on the side of conservatism so what do
you make of the prospects for
those on your side of the political
aisle well i'll give you hope
again i remember there's a chesterton
quote that said it's the job of
liberals to go on making mistakes and
it's the job of conservatives to make
sure those mistakes are never corrected
and
that's a little bit depressing but but i
think there is hope
you're so right to observe that i
observed that these these uh old
republicans
are always considered wonderful guys but
the new republicans are always hitler
they called
reagan hitler they called the bushes
hitler they obviously we remember they
called trump hitler and they still are
doing that
uh but then and then now george w bush
has been rehabilitated because now he's
a really nice guy
a few conservatives are willing to make
strong arguments that the two exceptions
and in recent memory are reagan
to some degree and trump to some degree
and what i mean by a strong argument is
arguments that do not accept the
premises
of our opponents arguments that are not
just
working around the edges trying to make
things a little more efficient
you know run the leftist programs just a
little bit better and manage it better
but actually challenge the fundamental
assumptions
the one issue that i think conservatives
have consistently done this on and they
actually have gained ground
is abortion the abortion debate
generally is not about
managing around the edges and working
here and there the abortion debate is a
debate
from justice it's a debate from reality
itself
it is simply a fact of nature that a
baby is a baby and the baby is not a
duckbilled platypus and a baby is not a
giraffe and a baby is not an appendage
of his mother a baby is
a baby and you should not kill that baby
in the womb and that's the way it is
that's the argument conservatives have
made and that is persuasive i think
but on so many other debates we're
unwilling to make that
argument you know on the issue of the
transgender bathrooms for instance
we keep making the argument well it's
it's harmful for women's sports
as if anyone really cares about very few
people care about women's sports
uh well if those of us with daughters
well you know we do care about women's
sports
i mean i don't mean to be flippant yes i
mean i you know women
there are plenty of interesting women
sports i like seeing venus and serena
williams
scream at the the coaches and the and
the referees
at wimbledon uh sure of course and i it
actually is very unfair
for girls who are competing in track
maybe they're trying to get scholarships
or something
and then men come in and beat them that
is unfair but i think
that's a side point i think the real
argument against
the radical transgender ideology that
has infiltrated our government and our
boardrooms and our schools
and our preschools for goodness sakes is
the fact of nature that
a human being cannot just change his sex
uh the the philosophical premise that
belies that or that that is underneath
transgenderism is this a gnostic heresy
this idea that my true self has nothing
to do with my body
that's simply not true or we know that
our person as old uncle aristotle will
tell us
is uh has something to do with our body
and something to do with our soul
something to do with the physical world
something to do with the metaphysical
world
and that's a that's an argument from
justice that's an argument from
philosophy
and it's an argument a lot of
conservatives don't want to make you
know
getting back to your point on debate
think about the debate
over redefining marriage this to me was
was one of the most telling examples
regardless of what you think about
whether or not we ought to call certain
same-sex
couples marriage or whether we shouldn't
call same-sex couples marriage
we never had a debate over marriage
there was there was no debate we had a
very powerful
radical interest in the institutions uh
come in and call the rest of us
bigoted if we held the view of marriage
that barack obama and hillary clinton
held as late as what 2012
i think the date was if we held the view
of marriage that everyone for all times
in all places
has held that sexual difference has
something to do with marriage
we were suddenly awful terrible bigots
who didn't want to give gay people poor
oppressed gay people the right
to be married the marriage debate never
was about
rights properly understood the marriage
debate was about a simple question
what is marriage and does sexual
difference have something to do with
marriage
but the institutions that control our
culture the media and the schools and
the government
and the supreme court that ultimately
decided it because of the romantic
poetry of justice anthony kennedy
who somehow found that the constitution
gives us a right to intimacy
which his colleague justice scalia quite
rightly noted
uh intimacy is is rather restricted by
the institution of marriage
ask the nearest hippie was it was his
line in the descent anyway i digress
we never had that debate because those
institutions shut it down they redefined
marriage as having nothing to do with
sexual difference
and so then when the debate became hey
should
people with different sexual preferences
have the same rights well if
of course they should nobody nobody
would suggest otherwise
the trick of that debate was that they
had redefined
the whole issue before anyone had the
opportunity
to actually debate it so so
one example among many of how if you can
control the language if you control the
words
you can control the whole culture and
then you can have a kind of mock debate
but that that doesn't really matter the
debate was already won
when they changed the words i wonder you
know by its nature
you know and i i speak mostly as a
political agnostic
you know i've supported democrats i
continue to support democrats locally i
continue to support republicans if
that's
if that's uh if they align with my value
system obviously
and and you know sometimes it could be a
one-issue voter if you know a particular
topic is is more important than others
but it seems to me if conservatives are
naturally
in a time lag scenario where they're
reacting
yeah we think of progressives as being
you know reactive or reactionary
but actually by its nature it seems to
me as a novice political theorist
that uh that conservatism by its nature
is fighting the you know skating to
where the puck was rather than where
it's going and i wonder with new
technologies coming on board and
actually conservatism
and your organization et cetera being at
the forefront of some of these things
you know kind of pre-empting cancer
culture by thinking
where's the puck gonna go and i'll give
an example podcasting you mentioned it
podcasting is one of the more durable
and less cancelable
sorts of media that we have right now of
course it doesn't stop
you know articles in the new york times
you know from coming down on people like
our mutual friend
eric weinstein and other people try to
cancel their podcast or what have you
but by the same token uh you can post it
on your own website as long as amazon
decides not to take down
aws uh and even that you could get
around so
uh what about like looking forward to
where it's gonna go instead of fighting
the the pronouns and fighting the the
marriage equity battles what's the next
issue pregaming that thinking where
that's going to be
and then not reacting to it but being
out in front of it what do you think
about that as a political threat
well the question is often framed is
this really the hill to dial
you know there's some and and i think
you're totally right conservatives are
usually
uh quibbling over issues at way too late
a stage at the point that we've already
lost
the issue of course with the hills
analogy is
if you refuse to die on any hill
eventually there aren't any hills left
i'm not in it i don't have any interest
in dying on a hill but i i think that
one has to be
willing to do that one needs to be
willing to risk
something or else we've simply
surrendered and so
yes you're right we're always so behind
the eight ball it seems that
all we ever seem to do is try to in bill
buckley's words standeth word history
yelling stop and and frankly a lot of
conservatives these days aren't even
yelling stop they're saying well slow
down just a little bit actually go by a
little more politely please so
the question has to be do we stand for
anything
and if we do what is it that we stand
for the reason i titled the book
speechless
is beyond the joke of the blank book
is that we spend so much time on the
right
prattling on about the abstract right to
freedom of speech or the abstract right
to freedom of belief
and yet when we have the opportunity to
say things
we don't really have very much to say we
don't really seem to believe
very much at all this is why whenever
republicans have managed
to rest a little political power out of
the system over the last several decades
what's the only thing we ever managed to
do cut taxes
that's the one thing we can always cut
taxes a little bit then they go right
back up when the democrats get in power
but we we never seem to do anything else
on every other major cultural issue
we have lost and the reason for that is
that the right to free speech
in the abstract means absolutely nothing
to people
who have nothing to say and when we
think about where did these ideas come
from and
you know the origin of it you go over
the history the kind of frankfurt school
is a very illustrative history in the
book i i enjoyed that and
and uh seeing some you know kind of
history as mark twain said
you know rhyming if not repeating but
wanting to
kind of move in a direction that i heard
you speak about on your podcast michael
noel's show and i know you've talked
about on your podcast with
um with senator ted cruz and that's this
notion of
uh of kind of mccarthyism and i want to
let you
kind of give a a full throated defense
of mccarthyism but before i do
i want to point out you know i am uh i
am affiliated with a
the arthur c clark center for human
imagination at uc san diego
where we value academic freedom we value
freedom of speech obviously
and but we also value science fiction
and i want to take you back to my
favorite science fiction book of all
time which is fahrenheit 451.
fahrenheit 451 which i'm sure you're
aware of has
a theme that ran through it with the
overarching kind of menace
of mccarthyism and ray bradbury said he
wrote fahrenheit 451
because of his concern that the mccarthy
era
would lead to book banning book burning
and in his later years commented on how
mass media reduces the interest in
reading literature
in that the threat was coming from the
right and
you're now not only agreeing with him
that the mccarthyism was from the right
but you're you're sort of seeming to
intimate that it's maybe not
an unhealthy thing so let's talk about
that uh mccarthyism as a force for good
how could that possibly be michael it's
a it's a movement around which people of
good moral fiber
can uh can circle the wagons
this was the language of william f
buckley jr most mainstream conservative
ever there was
who wrote a book length defense of
mccarthy he late in later years he came
to temper
some of that defense really really for
more practical reasons actually than
anything
because mccarthy sort of self-sabotaged
uh but for many years buckley defended
mccarthy and for good reason
to to this point on on fahrenheit 451
the prediction was that if we do not
stop joseph mccarthy and mccarthyism
why then we'll get books banned books
burned we'll live in this
dictatorship of an increased censorship
that could never happen
so well what happened we defeated
mccarthy and we defeated mccarthyism
and now we've never burned books nearly
as much as we are doing right now in
america
i think that the fears of mccarthyism
were extraordinarily overblown i think
that the
anti-mccarthy forces also known as the
communists
that's who he was fighting and the
fellow travelers and the useful idiots
of the communists
are far more liable to burn books and
censor people
and worse yet they're going to burn bad
they're going to rather they're going to
burn good books and they're going to
censor
people who have something important to
say you know
joe mccarthy during his life before he
unfortunately kind of sabotaged and
fizzled out
had some great admirers from from across
the political aisle not just bill
buckley not just
every virtually every prominent
conservative but the kennedys i mean
john f kennedy was a big admirer of joe
mccarthy
when joe mccarthy died robert f kennedy
bobby kennedy attended his funeral i
mean
they were really staunch defenders of
the man
what mccarthy the history mccarthyism
has been so
horribly revised by by fiction writers
who masquerade as historians but the
claim about mccarthy is that
there were no communists in the
government it was a red scare there were
no that's just simply not true
we know there were very high profile
communists in the government we
prosecuted them
most notably alger hiss alger who was a
high-ranking state department official
he had been at the doj
he was a spy for the soviet union he
helped form the united nations and
actually
the way that we found out about him was
because his former
communist ally whitaker chambers came
out and testified against him and wrote
an excellent book on this called witness
so that was true harry dexter white a
top-ranking communist in the federal
government i mean this was really
happening
and uh and they say that mccarthy never
got a conviction
mccarthy's job was not to prosecute
mccarthy was the united states senator
mccarthy was able to bring bring names
there were many many communists who were
prosecuted in the united states as well
they should have been
you know there was a separate issue
which is the hollywood blacklist
communists were being blacklisted in
hollywood and i find it so rich
when culture cultural conservatives
today who say that we need to
you know take back the culture take back
hollywood take back the academy
when they speak ill of the hollywood
blacklist
these same cultural conservatives are
implicitly calling for the
for blacklisting communists we are
implicitly saying in some
in some cases at least in my case
explicitly saying we need to kick the
communists out of
hollywood we need to kick them out of
the academy
they are undermining students education
there is a thought that stops thought
and that
thought ought to be stopped to quote gk
chesterton radical theories that
contributed to political correctness
like critical race theory
which is a derivation of the frankfurt
school project of critical theory that
actually undermines a student's
education and i'll give you an example
of how
the premise of some of these kooky
academic theories
notably critical race theory is that
objective truth does not exist
there is no objective truth there is no
objective reality everything is words
words words
everything is socially constructed we
can remake society
as we like some other radical theorists
from the 20th century i think of people
like jacques derrida who says there is
there is no outer text which has been
interpreted to mean there's nothing
outside of the text it's all just words
if you teach a student
that they cannot rely on their faculties
of reason that there is no such thing as
objective truth
you are not expanding their education
you are
undermining their education because
education relies
on the existence of our faculties of
reason
and on objective truth when we talk
about expanding the curriculum
you'll hear this a lot they'll say we at
yale they did it we need to decolonize
the english department to expand it
and make it first of all i don't know
how do you decolonize an english
department by kicking out all the
english writers that seems like
that seems like colonizing it doesn't
seem like decolonizing but
neither here nor there they say we need
to be more inclusive
and so we're going to add i don't know
into the curriculum we're going to add
some useless writer like robin d'angelo
these race hustling people or ibram
kendy
all the critical race theorists that
does not expand the curriculum you know
this very well
you cannot expand a curriculum because
there's only so many weeks in the
semester
there are only only so many hours to
teach and you have to make certain
choices
and when you teach one thing you are
inevitably
not teaching something else and you know
the left understands this very well the
wright used to understand this
very well and uh i think the the right
has just bought into the left's crazy
talking points now and so
the language that we use on mccarthyism
or free speech or or academic freedom or
whatever
this is all the language that the left
used to use in the 1960s and 70s as i
think
a disingenuous ploy and conservatives
then opposed it
now the only people left using this kind
of shallow language i think
is the the squishy right and it's why i
think we've we've lost so much ground
yeah i mean just hearkening to cut the
college campus that i inhabit uc san
diego
and you know we can uh take you next
time you come to
town i can uh we can go have a meal at
the che
cafe so we have a uh we have a cafeteria
named after
che guevara with his painting on it
lovingly adorned
along with karl marx and and many other
people
and the the comment i always wonder is
do these students who are
you know uh come from all different
racial and
gender orientations uh and so forth do
they know his history and i don't think
that they do i don't think that they
know
what a what a vicious racist person he
was what a homophobe he was
and uh and it's painful to walk by kind
of an illustration of such a person
along with karl marx and and that really
brings up this this comment that i feel
nowadays is really quite pernicious
which is
that the academy is also accusing itself
of being systemically racist in other
words that that the physics department
that i inhabit potentially
or physics in general or journals like
nature and science
that they can be riven with um with
anti-black racism
uh et cetera at one hand it seems
impossible almost tautological for me to
refute it i know
if i see a racist i want to punch him in
the face i hate racism i hate
anti-semitic as a jew i've suffered
from anti-semitism it's still the best
country in the world to live in as a jew
right
but the point is uh i find these notions
of boring and yet i'm told that i have
to receive training in order to combat
my
my implicit racism but i say wait a
second i don't know anybody who's going
to admit that they're a racist
and i'm certainly not a race i hate
racism i really i do
and and so because of that we can't
falsify it and that really brings up
this notion of karl popper who said that
the notion of real science is that which
can be falsified
and at the time in the 30s he was really
arguing against uh systems like
dialectical materialism and
communism uh and phrenology and and even
psychology and dream interpretation but
anyway
we get into the situation if i call you
michael i say michael you're
what anti-anti-semitism are you working
on today i mean
you can't refute that so yeah do you
have any advice for
academics that you know are abort find
racism abhorrent detestable hateful
and repugnant to us but we also don't
want to
say that you know we have to undergo
training to become less racist because i
don't feel that i am and then i'm told
that that's a sentiment of
you know exhibiting my potential uh
dissent into this important trait so
where do you take this where does this
all lead to here's how i respond to
these people brian you might be familiar
with this gesture but i will
instruct your audience if not you take
your hand and you put it underneath your
chin
and you flick your hand out this is an
italian gesture antonin scalia got in
trouble for doing this to a reporter
it means no mene frega i don't care i
don't care what you have to say you
crazy people
it's so silly because by the way not
only is it
unfalsifiable when they accuse you of
the implicit racism
but if you refute it if you protest
they will say that your protestation
your denial is
evidence of your even greater racism
that if you were
slightly less racist you would at least
be aware of what a vicious racist you
are it's all very silly stuff
it's not worth taking seriously these
sorts of people the deputy assistant
deputy deputy dean of inclusion and
diversity and diversity
they are mere parasites and leeches on
the university
the robin d'angelos of the world are
absolute extortion artists
and you saw this actually recently with
patrice cullers who was the co-founder
of black lives matter and a vowed
marxist herself
as she recently had to step down because
she
managed to transform blm from black
lives matter into by large mansions
she was caught uh spending millions of
dollars on
on these mansions and the way she got
the money by the way was not embezzling
it
from the cash rich 60 million dollars
cash on hand
blm organization they raised 90 last
year it's because she had a separate
group
that would go it was a consulting firm
she'd go into local governments
and other organizations and she would
say look if you want my stamp of
approval that you're not racist you need
to pay me money to give you these sorts
of ridiculous
training sessions and that's documented
michael that that's been documented
that is documented it's actually it
wasn't the conservatives that that
uncovered this it was actually other
rival blm organizations
who got a little upset that she was
skimming so much money
that that they looked into it and she
she all but admitted this recently when
she resigned from the organization
uh so you know to me it's a total grift
it's a con there's no reason to pay
attention to it
the question that i ask these people
when they throw this word racism around
a word that has now been defined into
nothingness
is i ask them why is racism wrong
why why is it wrong why is it a bad
thing i think it's a bad thing
i i i don't engage in it but i think
it's wrong
because man is made in the image of god
and so that's right racism is an offense
against human dignity
simple it's easy i don't need to you
know flagellate well as a catholic i
suppose i could fluctuate myself anyway
but
i don't need to go on and on about oh no
seriously believe me i'm not a
it's very simple not a racist because i
believe man's made in the image of god
and it's an affront to human dignity
done [ __ ] and spam
why do you woke person believe that
racism is a bad thing they won't have it
they
usually don't believe in god they
certainly don't believe in human dignity
they won't have an answer to it actually
their answer will usually be that
i don't know black people or whatever
name whatever victim group
is a special class and deserve special
privileges which of course reveals that
they themselves are engaging in a sort
of racism to say
that white people are irredeemable which
is what many of them say
is to engage in a kind of racism so what
you what you reveal of course
is what they refer to as racism is
nothing of the sort
it's just a cudgel it's just a word with
which
they can beat their political opponents
into
silence and leave them speechless and
when i yeah yeah
that's how he turned back to the cover
of the book it's a good truman capote
would be proud of you you have
he said a boy must hustle his book but
let me let me take the
uh the steel man opposing position so
also at uc san diego
we were the first university to offer a
tenured position to
a physicist by the name of maria
gephardt mayer she was a jewish woman
but she was also a woman
and she was denied a 10-year role at
university of chicago at argonne at
hopkins
and we were one of the first
institutions to take her and
actually she had some difficulty along
with other people getting housing in the
early 60s because there was a covenant
against jews buying property you shall
not it said in the original title to my
home
in san diego and in la jolla it said you
shall not sell to a black a jew or a
mexican
uh so i by the way parenthetically i
think scientifically racism
is evil and abhorrent and
self-destructive because
we we know that uh but merely assuming
the most basic characteristics about a
person
are somehow indicative of their
intellectual power and shutting that out
of the scientific endeavor that is
intrinsically anti-scientific
if i judge somebody and say because
they're black or because they're a woman
that is repugnant and abhorrent and uh
but it's fundamentally anti-scientific
also it's excluding scientific progress
and no good scientist worth his or her
their salt
would want to exclude scientific
progress and preclude it we'll go
into more detail on that later but i
want to ask you i asked heather mcdonald
your fellow
yale graduate i said heather how do you
do you think scientists have changed in
100 years
and she said no science is about a
meritocracy and i said
oh yeah well einstein couldn't win the
nobel prize for about 15 or 16 years
because
he was basically because he was a jew
and if you don't think that
scientists change over time as i don't
either
how can you really refute the statement
that that you know science is
systemically plagued with sexism with
racism etc in other words
we had bands we had covenants we had
restrictions
against jews and women and blacks why is
that not why are you so confident
that that's not an issue today michael
yes no i think this is a very important
point and i think it's one where
conservatives
get things pretty wrong you know the
language that has cropped up over the
last 30 40 years
about equality of opportunity
and about how you know everybody in
america is on equal footing
today i think it's a little overstated i
mean
certainly people have immense
opportunity here today but
history matters i wish conservatives
would recognize we seem to know that
at least when we're speaking
specifically about the study of history
but then we don't apply it to the
situation today
it is it is a fact half my family came
over on a sardine boat
but the other half came over on the
mayflower and i can trace my lineage
back
and it gives me a certain perspective on
the country and i suspect no matter how
much i love my country and how grateful
i were
if my ancestors had come over on a slave
ship i would have a different
perspective
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so
[Music]
you